speak to us and we'll tell you who you
are software company procedure
technologies formerly called sigh where
says it has a program that can create
personality profiles based on just a
15-minute voice recording speech
analysis tools that can identify a
suitable applicant a dream if you're
hiring psychologist and CEO Christian
grave worked on the algorithm kabukiman
stage there are two relevant channels
first there's your voice how louder how
high are you speaking then there's what
you say the words you use not really the
concepts they convey but whether you use
emotional words or certain elements our
technology is based on this combination
of voice and speech against the end
additionally sticked could you really
break down my personality on the phone I
decide to take the test a recorded voice
poses questions when I've run out of
things to say I press a button and it
asks for next one please describe your
typical Sunday yeah many sometimes when
I get up on sunday mornings nowadays
it's usually little earlier than I'd
like because I've got a little daughter
does rattling on about my Sunday really
reveals things about my personality
whether I'm a team player or even a
possible leader surely speech is always
different depending on who you're
talking to how you feel and what you're
discussing the mall Fiscus tricked us we
discovered that after around seven to
nine minutes a voice print or profile
crystallized that was very individual
it's a little like a fingerprint we
can't get rid of it mid something
characteristic youngish paha concession
it recruiters consulting agencies and
health insurers are already using the
software to screen employees precise
says this kind of analysis can improve
communication among staff recognize
burnett and depression at an earlier
stage and pinpoint people with potential
the photo software the advantages of the
software are that it's very objective
and can return results quickly when
creating a personality profile it
achieve stable results from less than 15
minutes of speech first immediate listen
its makers claim the algorithm analyzes
over 500,000 speech characteristics but
exactly which ones and how they weighed
them is a trade secret as of Youngman we
focused very strongly on the scientific
parameters the algorithm is based on
science that's what we focused on often
focus off cause it's for decades
professor Vytas and Amaya has been
investigating speech and its effects
he's skeptical that current software
could make a reliable analysis
fundamentally is the human ear is still
the best acoustic analyzer if what you
want to do is recognize and process
human speech still just because we human
beings are able to do it well doesn't
mean that machines couldn't do it just
as well or just as quickly or just as
reliably he doubts precise software
could really create a profile from a
phone interview this is evil in Walmart
that these things are highly dependent
on what you're talking about who you're
talking to and the context for example
you'd speak to a child differently than
to an adult you talk to your best friend
differently than you would to a
policeman and so on my personal profile
is ready in 48 hours first Christian
glib tells me how I speak and how my
speech affects others overall I speak
clearly but my sentences are longer than
average I talk very quickly and don't
pause much
the Schneider speaking fast is generally
positive dynamic but it can also cause
you to leave a topic in the dust
especially when your sentences are long
p own company said setlist lens need we
never judge based on the speed of speech
alone if someone speaks quickly but
articulates well with proper intonation
and pauses then as a listener you don't
feel he's speaking too fast dimensioni
sushma it isn't clear from the test
results exactly which parameters have
been evaluated ight of the suppose at
half a million of them only a few make
an appearance one of them is volume I'm
surprised to hear I'm louder than
average he's often amber Nia but the
recordings are made by her phone
connection so the caller could be
dialing in from a smartphone or a
landline and everybody holds the phone a
little differently so it makes no sense
to compare the volumes of different
people then things get more personal
grave explains how the press I off I'll
says I tick and what the results of the
test could actually mean dominance
dominance is generally about power and
as often desirable in leader figures
your average in this trade so you could
take on responsibilities but aren't
driven to Muslims some parts of the
analysis seem accurate others feel way
off the mark so does the software work
or is it just a gag being sold as the
real thing see Dad Z quote you're happy
to take responsibility and make
decisions but are less interested in
having power over or controlling others
depending on the situation you prefer
guidance in other words anything is
possible this pattern is the same one
you'll find in horoscopes there's
something for everyone everyone picks
out an aspect that sort of fits and
thinks how do they know that in the end
I can't research how well the program
has fulfilled its developers promise the
software itself remains pretty
mysterious when it comes to the science
there are a lot of open questions
but precise is already on the market and
a major consulting firm predicts that
within 10 years programs like it will be
having a huge effect on the economy a
fascinating thought and a pretty
frightening one as well